[Musica]
la luce bianco fine agosto per dire
bella tutti immagino bella tutti sti
cazzi si inseriva ok abbiamo le prove di
ragazzi è bene non deve solo video sono
pari j e sono bicorna questo è just
dance quello nuovo
la novità di questo just dance è che in
realtà non ci sono più i telecomandi c'è
si balla come dei minchia a massimo tira
fuori il penny no no quello genere tuo
sicuro è sicuramente oasi romeno avuti
oddio casa romei martin garics gli
alberghi a te ti vedo molto più su
rabbiosa fare martin si lo so lo so che
ruolo ha fermi tutti
ah ecco ti metti cosa nuova giunta che
pagheremo noi siamo piazza 6 fa vj
sempre comunque non just dance
ha preso quindi la pone davvero non lo
so jack sia peso più direzioni joystick
mafioso locale
oddio passo sbagliato la sua sinistra
nemmeno capiscono e dietro nonno chiudi
albergo l'altro motivo cosa vuol dire
provare la direzione è la cosa più non
si scusa aiuto dove sono più di
sincronizzato di un'anatra porta la
sporta
so che ci fosse una patch amodio e so
che cosa hanno
questa cosa bella
no proprio questo no ti prego ma non sta
prendendo nulla di mastella ce l'abbiamo
ma vabbe che culo cosa è aspetta perché
di fatto morire
martin garisenda dopo ma come da ma fino
a ieri ti piaceva ma non è vero
by come se ci stessimo puntando 2
pistola alla tempia e marmo nel caso lo
vogliamo fare siamo noi a dover
addirittura cos'è questa cosa aspetti
era finita ma è possibile guardare
mostriamo brega fine a vita io ho vinta
vale di 2 punti in croce aveva però
contro zero
esce il tipo che ha fatto cos'è la lega
ad ora no le ospiti fare che poi
condividerlo su facebook poi cos'è sta
merda
cazzo non voglio al sud è bellissimo è
bellissimo ma certo fatto i momenti
salienti capitolo questo ragazzi e
l'orgasmo per chi non conoscesse quando
si proprio caso secondo dalla io non ci
parlo con te sembra non figura c6 grigio
ha scritto il culo chi è che fa non farò
come vivo uscita che io sono la donna
perché c'è una volta come posso farlo io
non prego si diverte io petto e più
bruno mars sono io perché sono mano
rossa occhio giusto ecco se no sei una
donna ma no è vero ma davvero devo fare
che se ne so che lo stesso prima
possibile come ahmed aperte quindi sono
ben si sono guardati
va bene che se lo zio non noto che su
una donna e si prendono ci abbiamo
cambiati noi la bocciò lecture le cose
possano registrando occhio medicinali in
questa roba ma su youporn
non fate screen no no questo no ti prego
[Applauso]
[Musica]
c'è un limite alle cosa questo lo voglio
far parlare alla nazione va da sé che è
oramai una parte di questa parte si nota
ho paura che no è no guardi con arci
alla fatalità
ok no e che provengono dai e aspetti la
t a si può mettere su youtube sarà ma se
lo tolgono è fini no grazie ho ancora
chiarite vinto tu non l'hai due stelle e
vinto truffa è se gli preferì tutti
guidati da c'è la donna e che sempre più
spiega concesso quello sempre all'auto
gialle leccese ma diego guardando se
abbiamo anche abbastanza bravi o no per
lo sviluppo nemmeno paperissima e una
per ipad
[Musica]
puoi farcela allora ci sono due tecnici
non voglia ed avanzava i pubblicitari
colpito tutto il settore effetto ci
siamo io sono sexy quello rosso tu sei
quello rosa adesso questo qua così sono
tutti uguali man lima robben dai pin e
orfani
adesso mi è proprio ma chi è ma non c'è
per me.non capisco la combo perfetta
qualche cazzo di seguirla solo massima
nella shanghai landini dei ai latte
gerardi euro mario playing dai che fai
questa cosa cosa ha visto oggi stessa
pressione e mamma oddio mi è arrivata
nessuna tutto stabilito ora così ora
così ma sai queste mele così ora 20 per
i quali peppe a caso ma con di maurizio
costanzo che di queste così quasi tre
stelle
tanta roba zio come tastiere to stelle
questi tre stelle cioè la mia fredda può
dire per le quattro puntate qui le 44
ma che quanto scritto da 4 6 4 stelle
ora mentre questa roba succede mai
oddio come questo così naso 47 entrambi
barca [ __ ] o al bar mia ragazzi quattro
stelle e mezzo si tirerà e 4 più di 1000
punti in più del king quad i just that
his new york sotto abitano signora di 90
anni che americano stata un impatto mare
che sta perde già avvenuto e sentire
sirene della polizia stanno arrivando il
real o il 90 e non voglio cos'è non lo
so ho quasi 5 stelle questa merda e non
so come uncensored possa condividere su
facebook e tagliare mia madre buona
fortuna ragazzi tutti i pollici in su
per se volete che noi possiamo bisogno
di dirlo che facciamo radiosa come
faccia chi era quindi non faccio
shaquille ortica mente che già
condannato anche ragazzine un computer e
qui l'episodio perché veramente siamo
più pezzati di non so cosa che ti della
mucca pezzata lunga pezza tema
quest'area che vi sia piaciuto adesso
mettiamo su ebay le nostre magliette su
tattiche prezzo di partenza a 5.000 euro
ci arrestano mestamente qualcuno conosce
la vecchia di sotto cavità di sotto non
siamo stati noi è stata la musica prende
ragazzi stalking che vi sia piaciuto
come seguita piaciuto lasciato momento
non mi piace anche per i facebook e con
i video tra tende a rob viso notiamo e
cioè il telecomando a questo è il nuovo
seccate devi parlare un'altra roba
quindi non cadra assolutamente lecito
chiedersi di scrivere ci vediamo subito
[Musica]
io non ballo vivo e che dovessi
prenderla al volo guardate che la
finalissima che ha detto se cadete viri
balla insomma chiediamo un'altra
possibilità solo perché so che è morto
perché lo sono anch'io se perdi stavolta
di parlare aiuto no no ci sei versioni
si dispiace ci vediamo al prossimo video
belle ragazze